was selena gomez intimidated working
with you too i would think that being on
a set with you two or you know what you
know i knew who selena gomez was but i
didn't know her work that well so i
looked her up
on you know the internet and i realized
at 28 she had done as many movies as i
had
right and i realized i'm working with a
absolute pro and i'd say we hit it off
really well
almost immediately i mean as the series
went on we developed that you know that
kind of rapport on the set that you i
you want so badly and when we met selena
the first day of shooting
right away you knew she wanted to keep a
joyful loose happy set and so we all
were similar and you know she's a pop
diva
you know she could be anything but she
you know
she comes to the set exactly on time we
all meet at the time there's no waiting
we run the lines together there's you
know it's it's all pro which is what we
we need all pro so later we can be all
creative what was that story i read that
she had to explain to steve what uh wap
stood for uh wet ass [ __ ] uh was that a
thing steve how did you uh absolutely
true
what happened and i didn't know this
song [ __ ] we're told now it's [ __ ]
and uh
and i didn't know this dog and she just
came up and said do you know this song
and i'm listening to the lyrics no and
now
i i knew songs existed that were very
frank and
you know i don't know what you call it i
would say that song is frank frank
but i didn't know because that goes back
a long time it goes back to the 80s
right this right you know rap and it's
very frank
and
uh but i didn't know they were number
one
right that'd be number one and then what
was the other
the other song you're a [ __ ] hoe yeah
yeah you know what this song she would
sing it and we would laugh you know yeah
have you guys become old farts in the
sense that when you hear uh wet ass
[ __ ] i don't absolutely i just go
that's that's what's happening and i've
i've made a conscious decision i
remember uh mike nichols said to me once
you know he was complaining about
something he said i don't know if i have
a legitimate complaint or if it's old
fogeism that's right
and i've just decided you know
there's no
way we used to do it i used to i heard
that all the time when i was starting
out and i just think you're wrong and
i'm not going to become that person the
way we used to do it what's so great
about the way we used to do it